we've learned it was the FBI's public
corruption unit that raided president
Trump's personal lawyer Michael Cohen
sources tell CBS News the search
warrants covered any evidence related to
agreements Cohen made with adult film
star stormy Daniels and Playboy model
Karen McDougal they both claim they had
affairs with mr. Trump more than a
decade ago major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning source close to
the investigation tells CBS News Daniels
is cooperating with the Justice
Department President Trump remains livid
about that FBI raid on his personal
attorney Michael Cohen's offices and
within the president's inner circle more
scrutiny negative scrutiny than ever is
being applied to Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein and with that scrutiny
comes increased anxiety about Rosen
Stein's
job security it's frankly a real
disgrace today after President Trump
framed the raid as an attack on the
country his personal attorney Michael
Cohen said the FBI agents who conducted
the raid were professional courteous and
respectful but he also acknowledged he
was worried about the investigation rot
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
in charge of overseeing Special Counsel
Robert Muller's investigation approved
the raids on Cohen's personal residence
hotel room and office many people have
said you should fire him
Monday night President Trump suggested
he may fire special councilor Muller and
on Tuesday White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders said mr. Trump believes he
has that authority certainly believes he
has a power to do so by law a special
counsel can only be removed by the
Attorney General but Jeff Sessions
recused himself from the Russia
investigation last March
leaving Rosenstein is the only one who
could dismiss Muller in the Oval Office
the president ignored questions from
reporters on who we might purge next on
Capitol Hill a bipartisan group of
senators is pushing for legislation to
protect Muller but most Republicans
don't think the president will go
through with it I don't think he's gonna
be removed from this office before those
highly critical comments from the
president came on Monday he was advised
internally at the White House not to
vent his anger in public he did so
anyway and that's contributed Norah to
an atmosphere at the Justice Department
and
year about anxiety about rosin Stein's
future Jeff Sessions future and lots of
gallows humor jokes checking Twitter
feeds to see if anyone has been fired
xiety continues major thank you